thank you very much
um let's let's start at the beginning
because
what what happened was that you became a
member of the north korean french
friendship association in denmark why
did you do that
well i i needed some something in my
life something is
interesting and well north korea has a
big
could relate a bit to my childhood when
i lived close to the border to
germany and those countries were
separated
and then i found out later in my life
that of course north korea was separated
but
i will try to understand why people
could support a regime like north korea
and a simple google search put me in for
the danish friendship association
and after two or three phone calls and a
few emails i
participated in the first meeting well
then i took contact with the director
mass breuker
and he made a documentary before about
north korea named the red chapel
and it was a crazy documentary and
almost like a comedy
but i asked him if he was interested in
letting me infiltrate this friendship
association because i found it quite
ridiculous and funny too but and he said
well why not try and keep me posted
and during a few during the next few
years i was getting a member of the
board
having a lot of uh new comrades um
which was older than me it launched
quite quickly
but but i i won't yeah so the first time
you went there
was your purpose was your plan to become
some sort of mole already from the start
well not not like it ended out to be but
you know just
try to film them in funny situations
defending north korea and all the
those absorb certain stories you're here
but but but tell me
i mean you're what about your wife you
had to travel a lot
uh with this new hobby of yours well i
i told her from the beginning that i
found north korea very interesting
and i would like to visit this
friendship association to hear some
stories and
meet new people just to try and
understand the country
and then i told her that i i could might
visit the country without if i had a
camera with to show you know funny parts
of it
um and she was like well you're quite a
nerd so
off you go this went on for
for more than 10 years and a
breakthrough moment is when you meet
alejandro de benos
alejandro caudabiner is a spaniard who
has
founded the kfa which stands for the
korean friendship association
and he is the president of the
association
and he has a lot of people all around
the world
which uh named the od official delegates
of a country or region and they could
pro you know defend north korea in the
media or
arrange meetings to tell the people
about how fantastic north korea is
and you know make damage control and
as a australian journalist once said
they are like useful idiots for north
korea
um protecting their country and when i
met him
um i met a spaniard in north korea in a
north korean military uniform which is
quite
funny to watch acting like a north
korean
and he was like the gatekeeper of north
korea like he
could choose who can come in and out
from you know from the journalist side
and for the travel
and tourist side and when he's in north
korea he is
really defending the country more than
he even is outside
and then um after i came back home from
this first trip to north korea
i spoke with the director that i think
he could be a game changer for the whole
plan and uh and then he
you very much gained his trust i mean
he's not here to defend himself today
but but
no how would you what part would you
give him in in this story
well he's the super villain he's the one
as we call himself he's the matchmaker
who makes things happen
i went after i went to north korea and
met him we have some
we had a lot of emails backwards and
forwards and
i then said to him i have a weekend in
barcelona and he lives in the area of
barcelona
maybe he could want to meet up with me
and he came to my hotel and we talked
three hours
and then he just said if ulrich if you
want to be my
official delegate in denmark it's yours
and of course i would love to be that
because
that could gain me even more trust in
north korea
and practically i didn't i've been home
for three or four days i got the first
email that he
if i knew somebody who would invest
money from 50 000 euros to a million
euros
we could do something and that's really
opened up the possibilities to show how
north korea is
and then the director came up with mr
james
which is uh his real name is jim letraz
and
he's a fantastic person with uh even
more fantastic acting skills um
and he knows the game because he's he
has a pass which is quite different from
many other people
and he knows this game to play well jim
has a history of being a
cocaine jet set pusher in denmark and
spent eight years in prison
and now is a legit businessman with a
got a great business in copenhagen but
he is not
he's not as rich as he pretended to be
no not at all but well the north korean
is under that much pressure
and since i i got a medal from the
regime in 2012
and alejandro which has a big star in
north korea
we just cleared him out for the north
koreans and
put up the meetings between jim and and
alejandro in
oslo and we
we didn't even use more than two minutes
then alejandro was
literally just open up this magic box of
weapons and
metamphetamine and everything is
possible in north korea
this was your mission when you and mr
james
went to or this actor who called himself
mr james
when when you went to pyongyang
it was to set up some business where you
could buy
weapons and and drugs
drugs yeah early in the morning when we
have
got our breakfast we sat in the car and
drove outside of pyongyang
and it was not the showcase city anymore
it was
the slum area with really
the buildings were literally falling
apart
i was practically really nervous
a bit scared because now we are in
some areas where western people never
comes and
and people at the street were looking
very strange of us
and when we went down this basement it
was like okay um
did they did they somebody blow our
cover or
did we blow it ourselves um but we were
met with a big door
um with uh with black leather and
like golden strips on and on the other
side of the door
there was this luxury conference room
with
food all over karaoke singing girls and
it was like a party and after the dinner
they just literally took like a minion
card and said here this is what we have
from weapons and
tanks everything mass destruction
weapons
gut missiles and then i ask well is it
possible for me to
to take some pictures or some film so mr
james can show his uh
partners in europe that we actually are
here and
we have achieved this meeting and so and
the north korean was like
of course you're a friend um even at a
point they just took the camera out of
my hand and started filming me
in in the group and i was like
this is so crazy um literally are we
gonna be shot after this because
now they're just playing us out but no
they were believing
hundred percent on us what what side of
your personality
has been to the most to your biggest
advantage
um what was the best for me was i had a
visit in uh
in washington dc with a previous ui
agent
and he taught me that to be a perfect
mole or perfect agent you need to be 95
percent yourself and 5 mole
because don't lie too much because it
will be too difficult to remember all
your lies
tell them you have your wife you have
children you live in the suburbs for
copenhagen
um give them your phone number give them
your email address um
you're going north korea you need to
fill out your address at home so
they got my address at that point um but
be be honest
and just just let this last five percent
be your
observation skills and and the skills to
open up the doors and that helped me a
lot because
i think when people today are trying to
to find nothing they are too making
things too difficult for themselves
if i should tell i wasn't having any
children or no wife or
i lived in another town at one point i
will make a mistake and
then my cover would be blown i mean this
this went far it when
you and mr james ended up doing a big
deal
uh uh about making a weapon
factory uh the the deal is off
uh and and uh everything is
is exposed now uh north korea
it should be said is also um uh
denying everything that's been said here
now
and i i wonder is there
have you ever been been worrying that
they actually played you
it's difficult to say but i don't think
so i think actually
they were into this business but of
course it's north korea
and you don't hear any businessman go
out in public and say
hey i got fraught by the north koreans
because that would be really bad for
their business in the future
so but i think the kind of documentation
documentary that we came out with are
showing how
it's possible to do and we got all the
evidence to that
which also now led me to have an
invitation from the united nations as
well
to talk about what i achieved during
these years
yeah uh so you are
invited to the united nations to talk
about this uh but
how about your wife we could see in the
clip
before we started the way where you're
actually telling her about what you've
been doing for the last 10 years
and she called you an idiot has she
forgiven you now
yes you have um the funny part is
uh the next day the day after um
i told her she was not talking about it
at all
but two weeks later she was like
all her minds just start to come on all
the questions came out and
and of course she was mad at me because
i didn't told any i was in practical in
the danger of my life
but she now understand if i told her
she would be too worried if when i was
gone or
at least she wouldn't even not let me go
out of the door anymore
but today she is proud of me and and is
still
trying to you know to understand
how i could be that kind of person for
so many years
um what are you thinking bjorn well um
i'm two things i'm really curious about
one would be just to hear a bit more
why did you do this thing it's such an
incredible adventure such a dangerous
thing
high stress life-threatening situations
you put yourself in year after year
and my second question is what's your
life like now as far as i when i read
the news
north korea seem to be quite dangerous
to make enemies with they kill people
outside of north korea that are not
nice to north korea
well the first question well as i said
in the beginning i
i missed something in my life something
exciting and trying to understand new
things
but at that point i was not
not even in my fantasy could think about
something like this
uh if i if that was the way i went into
this project i think that uh
mess boyega and peter engler producer
would say this man is a maniac
but but but well it advanced slowly and
getting bigger and bigger and all the
opportunities that alejandro came up
with was
very interesting to follow um
so and to the second question um
of course north korea is dangerous
but and they don't have the history to
to try to hurt other people than their
own nationality outside
of korea right yeah but and now
at the moment we have this coveted 19
virus i think it would be quite
difficult for north koreans to go to
denmark
but of course there's a lot of security
around my person now
and i'm quite aware where i'm going
when i'm going or if i'm going a new
place i
normally check it out two hours before
just to be sure that
things looks normal
talk today we'll talk today bjorn
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations
please hit subscribe